hey guys I'm writing right a lot of
people say they think my review style is
a little too similar to Jeremy Jones but
it's Jeremy Jones willing to do this
that's right I'm reviewing in my
Avengers underwear am i desperate for
laughs oh yeah all right so this show is
called straight to the point somebody
start making these reviews a little more
straight to the point first off you got
to understand that this film it won't
ever be as exciting as the first one
simply because there's nothing that will
beat the first time you see all these
guys come together I mean the
performance is a really strong back
didn't feel like it really elevated
their characters to another level I mean
the only one who I can see out of the
four main Avengers who is really
different
after the outcome of this would probably
be Tony Stark because he's the idiot who
helped put together Ultron damn it
Robert Downey jr. can't ask about your
personal life but you [ __ ] up everyone
else's I felt like most of the
characters didn't really have their
chance to shine unless there was like an
action scene the action scenes are
[ __ ] great but I didn't feel like the
characters themselves didn't really get
a shine in a lot of the actual dialogue
driven scenes that's another thing this
movie is way more dramatic than the
first Avengers like it's much more
serious yes there's still humor here and
there but for the most part it's very
serious and much darker like how most
sequels like to do it and honestly I
feel like this donkey used a little bit
more humor the drama was it was good but
I didn't really feel a lot of the drama
at times I was honestly kind of bored
this plot is not exactly the most
original thing ever
helping create a I AI then rebels
against you and wants to wipe out the
world yeah we've seen that done before a
billion times but in the first Avengers
not going to keep them hearing them by
the way but in the first Avengers these
dudes took on eight god I'm pretty sure
they could to be a I so it was never
really that
tonight here's where people are like is
Loki technically a god I mean don't get
me wrong some characters to get a lot
more development I love what they did
with Hawkeye he wasn't like my favorite
one when I walked out of this movie but
I feel like he really did get a chance
to show more of his emotional side see
more of his actual character he helps
sustain that sense of humor and he was
still badass I like what they did with
Black Widow you actually get to really
see a much more sensitive side to her
and she still kicks ass looks great in
that suit that ass of Scarlett
Johansson's is just have to new main
characters Quicksilver Scarlet Witch
Quicksilver I liked him I mean I
couldn't help myself would be like I
like the one more in Days of Future past
but for this particular story this
Quicksilver is better and all you
[ __ ]
god damn comment boxes spoiler the
goddamn movie for me not gonna say what
the scene was but damn it Scarlet Witch
I really liked her powers I like how
they use them the character I thought
was written better than the actual
performance was I'll need to take a
second look at it I was mainly
distracted by how fake her accent
sounded it just did not sound real to me
and I wish they didn't give away that he
is in this movie they show him in a
trailer they even released the movie
clip vision is in this vision was
[ __ ] awesome
at one point vision had a moment just a
character moment that was so great you
guys probably know what I'm talking
about you've seen it where everyone in
the audience was like whoa and in terms
of Bruce Banner is the Hulk not much
different he's still like but the way
how they ended his character in this
movie it made me interested like I would
really like to see a standalone Hulk
movie that takes place after age of
Ultron and stars Mark Ruffalo because
I'd be interested to see where his solo
journey takes him now
and there were times where it was like
definitely choppy sometimes it felt
pretty and even talking how did I almost
[ __ ] forget about this guy Ultron
James Spader does the voice of Ultron I
I think he did motion capture don't
quote me on that I don't know but I
liked his portrayal he wasn't a typical
day I rebelling there was even not kind
of a quirky sense of humor about him
sometimes even though I never really
felt like the Avengers were ever
lose I still found him to be pretty
scary out of the phase two movies I
would say Captain America Winter Soldier
is still my favorite one at the end of
the day when you get all these Avengers
together what you're gonna want is some
cool superhero fight scenes and be
really [ __ ] fun and those were the
best parts of age of Ultron like with
the Avengers some of my favorite scenes
are actually just interaction with them
in this movie the interaction wasn't as
appealing to me it was still good but it
just wasn't as strong for me I mean
don't get me wrong the first movie had
great action scenes but I thought they
even improved this time around the
beautifully [ __ ] shot the characters
really gonna show off even more of their
powers they weren't really well together
and there's a lot of action there's a
lot of action in this film so I know I
was a little nitpicky here and there and
there were some things that I really
didn't like but like I said it's really
about is this entertaining is he
actually gonna [ __ ] rock I'm not the
most comic-book savvy as most of you
guys have probably noticed but in terms
of just the film that I was watching I
thought when the action was there there
was plenty of it and I always found a
really cool to watch that whole Buster
versus Hulk scene oh yeah yeah
I gotta get a whole Buster of my Monday
take care of one of my neighbors anyone
loved it as much as the first Avengers
but does it live up to being a summer
blockbuster that is really entertaining
yeah I'd definitely say so well let me
get straight to the point here all in
all I gotta say Avengers age of Ultron
got it entertainingly react
I will be doing a spoiler review of age
of Ultron people look out for that my
opinion sometimes changes this is my
first impression at the movie so if you
watch the spoiler my opinion might
actually be different at that time last
but not least you want to get updated
every time one of my reviews or videos
this out do any good on this but my mind
dicta subscribe that's right
the Jack let me tell you something about
this little Avenger every time he gets
ready to satisfy his own personal Black
Widow
he gets his hardest iron that's big and
veiny so green that vain monstrous [ __ ]
and then he bangs as hard as a hammer
and when he gets ready to release his
arrow on his girl's face she shields
herself yep I included all them